Narrator:
This is the Shark Tank,
where entrepreneurs
seek an investment
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
Wondercide solves a problem
that affects everyone.
[ Scoffs ]
America, you are welcome!
Narrator: If the Sharks
hear a great idea...
Come into my office here.
Narrator: ...they'll invest
their own money...
Our total gross margin
is 70%.
Ooh.
That's like
talking dirty to me.
Narrator: ...and fight
each other for a deal.
Have you guys ever
partnered up before?
Not a chance in hell.
Oh, come on.
I'm not interested in that.
Narrator: The entrepreneurs
must get the full amount
they're asking for, or they'll
walk away with nothing.
We have
absolutely no debt.
How would you like some?
Not gonna work.
Last offer,
and you should take this.
You'd be foolish not to.
Give us, uh, one second?
You just have to say
yes or no.
You got to decide.
You're not gonna love this.
Narrator:
Who are the Sharks?
They're self-made
business experts worth billions.
Kevin O'Leary is
a shrewd venture capitalist
who made his fortune
selling a children's
educational company
for over $4 billion.
Daymond John dominated
the fashion world with FUBU.
Now he's the branding expert
behind multiple global brands
generating billions in sales.
Robert Herjavec, son of
an immigrant factory worker,
founded one of
the world's preeminent
cyber-security firms.
Lori Greiner, the Queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents
and has launched
more than 400 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in sales.
And Mark Cuban,
esteemed billionaire tech mogul
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
I'm Ozzy.
And I'm Mike.
And we're from Pittsburgh,
Pennsylvania.
I'm an attorney,
and I fight for victims
who have contracted lung cancer
and mesothelioma.
And I'm an executive
in the food business,
monitoring our quality
in food safety.
We can do that.
We've come up
with one of the coolest products
that's ever been invented.
That is brilliant.
And we think it's gonna
change lives.
Hit it, son! Whoo!
Every year at Memorial Day,
we go to my hunting cabin
just to get away from things
and clear our mind.
It was on
one of these getaways
where we started brainstorming
our business idea.
Before we knew it,
we had come up with the solution
to a problem that had been
plaguing us for years.
It's perfect.
We didn't know how
we'd lived without it,
and we thought
it was our obligation
to share it
with the world.
The reason we want
to get a deal with a Shark
is they have contacts that
we couldn't dream of having.
We need a Shark to get
our product to the masses.
Cheers, my friend.
This isn't just about us.
It's about America and
making people's lives better.
We're hoping to stay cool
under pressure if we can
and land a deal
with a Shark.
Hello, Sharks.
I'm Mike.
And I'm Ozzy.
And together,
we run the Beer Blizzard company
based in Pittsburgh,
Pennsylvania.
What?!
[ Greiner and Cuban chuckle ]
Sharks, we're here
for a $100,000 investment
for a 20% equity stake
in our company.
Mikey here is the C.E.O.,
but I'm the C.R.I.C. --
Chief Redneck in Charge.
[ Chuckles ]
And being
the Chief Redneck in Charge
makes me an expert
in two categories -- fashion...
[ Greiner laughs ]
...and beer.
And I'm gonna tell
you Sharks something --
warm beer sucks.
Sharks, beer tastes great,
but it's got to be ice-cold.
You know that.
But the problem with beer is
once you get down
to around here,
that ice-cold beer,
it ain't so ice-cold anymore.
Something
had to be done.
And you know what, Sharks?
We did do something.
When Ozzy and I noticed
that all aluminum cans have
the exact same
dome-shaped bottom,
we had an "aha" moment
and came up with a great idea
that we are sure is the cure
for warm beer.
Introducing...
Together:
The Beer Blizzard.
It's a reusable plastic
dome-shaped ice cube
designed to fit
the concave bottom
of all aluminum beer
and soda cans on the market.
The Beer Blizzard is
really simple to use.
All you do is freeze it and
insert here for ice-cold beer.
[ Sighs ]
Ahh.
[ Chuckles ]
Ahh! America,
you are welcome!
[ Laughter ]
Sharks, Ozzy and I have
been in business
for just over a year now,
and ever since we launched
our company on Kickstarter,
we've had
a ton of success.
Hangovers.
[ Chuckles ]
Now, we know
you Sharks love money,
but the world loves beer.
Ice-cold beer.
So, the question is
how many of you Sharks
want to line up with us
and help make the Beer Blizzard
the second greatest invention
in the history of mankind?
What was the first?
All: Beer.
Now, we're gonna
offer you Sharks
an ice-cold beer
and a Beer Blizzard
for you to look at
before the Q&A begins.
Robert.
Oh, thank you.
You're welcome.
Cheers, Lori.
Hopefully it's your brand.
Greiner:
I have a question.
Have you ever done testing?
How long would it
keep your beer cold?
Mikey and I had the product
C.A.B.-certified
by an independent accredited
third party laboratory
in Atlanta, Georgia.
Basically, what it says is that
on a warm day outside,
if you open your beer can,
you've got about six minutes
to consume it
before the
"warm beer suck zone."
Yeah.
Now, by using
the Beer Blizzard disc,
you now have 21 minutes
to consume your beverage
under those
same conditions
before the temperature
of that beer --
Greiner:
So, in 21 minutes --
It stays cold for 21 minutes
with or without an insulator?
With the insulator.
So, all testing was done
with the insulator.
Correct.
You could use
any one of these, right?
That's correct.
Every can insulator is designed
to that specification.
What happens
when you test it
with just an insulator
and no Beer Blizzard?
And no Beer Blizzard?
Oh, we didn't test it
with just the --
We didn't do that.
Cuban:
Can we see the packaging?
We haven't really seen
the packaging.
O'Leary:
Ozzy, there are solutions that
stay frozen longer than water.
Yes, sir, there are.
Is this one of them?
Yes.
Did you patent this shape?
Uh, we have two patents pending.
We have a design patent
and a provisional utility patent
that's pending right now.
Hey, guys, does it work
with soft drinks?
Absolutely.
Sure.
'Cause aluminum cans all have
the same shape.
What?
So, you know,
you named it Beer Blizzard,
but it could be
so much wider range to sodas
and anything
that's in a can, right?
Correct.
So, did you ever think
about that?
Like, that this -- this makes it
seem like it's just for beer?
Yeah, I mean, when you look
at that, Lori, I agree with you.
It limits it --
limits it just to beer.
But honestly, Ozzy and I, we've
talked about this many times.
But to be frank with you,
there hasn't been many times
I've been
walking around Pittsburgh,
and I saw
somebody with, like,
a can insulator with a Coke
in it, you know?
It's --
You know, it's beer.
This product is for beer.
We're beer drinkers.
We love sports and beer,
and that's what we do.
Good point.
And I think that's our market.
I think that's --
A good point.
I think it's a mistake
to focus on --
Yeah, I-I honestly
don't really know.
Great answer.
On your website,
does anybody write reviews
or say anything
about it?
No, we get a lot of e-mails,
and a lot of people --
We -- This is how we know
people love it,
because when --
when we get an order,
I e-mail
every single person.
I say,
"Thank you for your order.
How did you hear
about us?"
Good for you.
And they always hear about us
one or two ways --
"I saw your ad
on Facebook,"
which is, "If you hate warm
beer, click here," or I was --
[ Laughs ]
Clever.
Or "I was at a party and my
buddy had one, and I want some."
Herjavec: How much did you raise
on Kickstarter?
Our Kickstarter campaign
was awesome.
Uh, we raised $43,000
in 45 days.,
We hit our goal
in just three days.
Wow.
And we had sales
to all 50 states
and 45 countries
around the world.
And what are your sales
a year later?
A year later,
we sold 66,000 discs.
We sell them in six-packs,
so that's 11,000 six-packs.
The gross was $156,000,
and the net is $135,000.
I'm assuming all online.
Uh, majority of it
is online.
Oh, I love it!
Hey, Ozzy,
where were you on TV?
It says "as seen on TV."
We just did that
for here.
[ Laughter ]
We -- We -- We wanted
to make it look good.
I wish I had
a better answer for you,
but we were drinking
when we came up with that.
[ Laughter ]
Have you approached
any beer companies
about putting their logo
on this?
Great promotional idea.
Yeah, we've made calls,
and they don't return our calls.
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
All: Ohh.
What?!
They will now.
What are you gonna use
the money for?
We want to buy in volume
to get our costs lower per unit.
By building up
our inventory,
increasing our profit margin
for each one,
we want to hire
a full-time fulfillment center
that could handle the orders,
handle the shipments.
Frankly, we're worried
if we're on here,
we're gonna get pounded
with orders.
I'm -- I'm scared
about it, honestly.
What is your, um, full-time job?
Or is this it?
Uh, no. I'm, uh,
I'm an attorney in Pittsburgh.
I represent, um --
Oh, you just blew it.
[ Laughs ]
Ah, I'm sorry.
But It's true.
I knew it. I knew it.
I knew it.
What kind of law?
Um, I represent,
uh, the hardest-working people
in America, people that get sick
from breathing asbestos,
factory workers --
Robert, like your dad --
uh, steel workers --
Mark, like all those guys
around there that, you know,
they bust their ass day in
and day out.
What does Ozzy do?
I am the director
of quality food safety
and regulatory affairs
for one of the nation's
leading food companies.
Who's gonna
run the business, though?
I mean, 'cause you --
you guys have both real jobs.
If we can scale this up
the way we want to,
I made my mark
on the food industry,
and it's time for me
to step down
and run our business.
Ozzy, I'm not sure you need
to step down.
I-I mean,
you guys did a great job,
and, I mean,
I love how you presented it.
But I really think
it's a one-shot product.
I really see it
as a promotional giveaway.
I don't see it
as something
you're gonna build
a business around.
Not for me. I'm out.
Hey, Robert,
we appreciate your advice.
We'll drink a beer with you
anytime. No hard feelings.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
John:
Uh, I like the product.
I just don't know the
clear direction to go with it.
Even though you're gonna
make this a full-time job,
it's not right now,
and I don't know
if I have the time and energy
to make all those calls.
I'm gonna have to pass
on this one. I'm out.
We're hard-working guys.
We're smart and dedicated.
When we need to get
something done, we get it done.
My clients --
I love my guys,
and I go up against the biggest
companies in the world
that you can imagine.
And when my guy walks into work
in the factory for 45 years,
and he's dying
from mesothelioma,
they're gonna try
and beat him up left and right.
I stick up for him,
and I bust my ass to make sure
that nothing happens
to that guy.
I will do the same thing
for your money,
and we'll do the same thing
for this business.
If you give us a shot,
I guarantee it will turn around.
But I'm just worried that,
you know, it's a product.
It's not really
a company, right?
Correct.
Cuban: Look, I like this,
and I like you.
Not every business has to be
$10 million in sales.
You guys do half a million
dollars in sales at 70% margins.
We'll all make money,
we'll all drink beer,
and we'll all have
a good time.
So, I'm gonna
make you an offer.
100k, but I want 25%,
'cause I have to negotiate.
Done?
But wait. There's more.
Oh, but wait.
I'm interested.
Slow down.
What if I did 100k
for 20%?
I don't think this is
just a promotional product.
I think this is
a great Bed Bath & Beyond,
Target,
all types of retail.
You got to decide.
Give us, uh, one second?
Uh...
Are you really
taking that time?
You drank
too much beer.
Yeah, are you taking
that time?
[ Whispering indistinctly ]
Lori's giving you exactly
what you're looking for, Ozzy.
No, we-- we're --
we're flattered,
but my partner here has
a serious man crush on Mark
'cause they're both
from Pittsburgh.
Who doesn't, you know?
We've selected Cuban, but
he's got to have a beer with us.
Done!
[ Laughter ]
Sorry, Lori.
I -- How do I compete
with a man crush?
Thank you.
[ Laughs ]
Amen, brother.
Cheers.
We're gonna go home and do
some research and development!
[ Laughter ]
Yeah!
Yes.
I love you, bro.
I love him, too, man.
I'm heartbroken, Mark.
They have a bigger crush
on you.
Ohhh!
Oh!
Thanks to Mark Cuban,
my partner Mikey Robb...
[ Chuckles ]
...and "Shark Tank,"
America, you will now
have cold beer
from the first sip...
Together: To the last.
You are welcome!
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a modern version
of a traditional machine.
Hey, Sharks.
I'm Brian Shimmerlik.
And I'm Steve Bofill.
We're from New York City,
and our company is Vengo.
We are seeking $2 million
for 12.5% of our company.
When you hear "vending machine,"
what comes to mind?
Most people imagine desperately
shaking this old machine,
trying to get that bag
of potato chips to drop out.
These machines are huge,
they're old, they're ugly,
and so they get hidden
in the basement.
Vengo is taking vending
out of the basement
into the spotlight
with the latest technology.
So, what's so different
about Vengo? Everything.
Let's start with size
and appearance.
Our slim-form factor
and attractive design
is the ticket to exclusive,
high-traffic areas.
Vengo hangs on the wall
like a picture frame
and requires
zero floor space.
Let me show you
how it works.
What Vengo does is
we bring video content
to the point of purchase.
Bofill: So, Brian will go ahead
and browse the products.
It looks like the Bottle
Breacher has caught his eye.
He adds it to the cart,
clicks "checkout."
Wait a minute, Brian.
I don't see any slots for coins.
Vengo is totally cashless,
totally digital,
very, very fast.
Once the payment is made,
our team at Vengo
back in New York
is automatically notified
of the sale,
and that's
just scratching the surface
with everything we can do
with the valuable data
from each and every vending
machine out in the field.
It's that easy.
Who's ready to Vengo?
So, it's small in size.
Yes.
Does that mean that anything
that you sell out of it
has to be small in size?
Absolutely.
This is about the largest item
that we can fit,
but we can actually fit
100 products.
How do we fit so much
in so little
is we have an amazing team
of aerospace engineers.
Is he
an aerospace engineer?
Yes, that's
my background.
I was an aerospace engineer
for about 9 or 10 years.
What happened to you?
Uh...
And now you're making
vending machines.
Now I'm making
Exactly.
I saw the opportunity,
I quit my aerospace job,
and I jumped to this.
See what happened
with the space program?
We're not
a vending operator,
and we're not
replacing vending machines,
but we are a software
and media company
that manages this digital
network from the cloud.
So, here's
our business model.
We sell the hardware
to vending companies.
So, let's go from there.
So, let's go from there, right?
So, you're selling to
vending-machine guys and owners.
Exactly.
So, let's go from there.
What does one of those cost
for me to buy
if I'm
a vending machine guy?
Yep.
What does it
cost you to make?
Yeah. You're not gonna
love this, so bear with me.
We build it for $2,500.
We sell it for $2,500.
Boo!
[ Chuckles ]
I understand.
I got it.
Okay, so you charge
a monthly, then.
So, what do you charge
on a monthly, then?
Exactly. We charge you
$20 per Vengo per month.
And what do I get
for that $20?
You get the front-end software
that controls the hardware.
Do I -- Does that include
maintenance in case it breaks?
Exactly. Yep.
We're --
Okay.
So, then do --
do the different companies
that you sell this to
select and choose
what's going to
go in the machine?
We control
the media rights,
and we control a significant
amount of the product mix.
And so, you can get
some of your products in
as the owner
of the hardware,
but we're also managing
this network remotely...
Right.
...working with
really great products
to get them into the Vengos
across the whole network.
What are
your total sales?
For this year, we're going to
generate $1 million.
Wow.
We just partnered
with the largest vending-machine
company in the country.
But, Brian, you make money
from the front of the screen.
You're an ad company.
Plain and simple, right?
Absolutely.
Let me tell you guys
what we're doing here.
Okay.
We are changing the game
on retail
and marketing
physical products.
That's a stretch.
Traffic into stores is down 50%
over the last 3 years.
The impulse purchase
at the checkout
at the grocery store
is down significantly.
Herjavec:
Brian, so, I'm an advertiser.
I want to advertise
on the front of the screen.
How do you charge me?
So, we're charging brands
$200 per SKU
per machine per month.
Wow.
Whoa.
What happens if they don't --
That's -- That's a lot.
Shimmerlik: And what --
And what that gets them is
we actually purchase
the product wholesale.
We sell it at retail.
We make sure
our vending partners can make
an attractive margin
and the product is --
So does it fit --
Guys, guys, look, I get it.
This is a digital end cap.
This is a digital end cap,
right?
Yeah.
Which is great.
But here -- here's my issue.
I invested in a company called
Oasis by women out of Boston.
They go into
women's restrooms
and all the products
are women's.
Now, we've designed
our own box.
I see them as competitive,
so for those reasons, I'm out.
Understood.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
Brian, why don't you
talk about
the $16 million valuation you've
put in front of the Sharks here?
John: Yeah, absolutely.
[ Greiner chuckles ]
Let's jump into that.
$2 million for 12.5%.
I'm gonna make the assumption
it's not supported by cash flow
because you don't have any.
So, there must be
some other reason
you think
you're still valuable.
It must be
that you have --
Have you raised
the money al-- already?
We've raised $3.4 million
from some of
the best investors out there.
The best investors in America
are right here.
You're talking to them.
Exactly.
That's why we're here.
And we always get great pricing.
I make sure of that.
I know you do.
Just explain to me how
it's worth $16 million today.
You might do $1 million in sales
this year.
Yeah.
Will you make any money
on that $1 million?
No, we will not.
We will lose
about $300,000,
uh, and then next year,
we will break even.
And so why is it worth
that much?
We've got an amazing team,
and we've spent three years
building out this platform.
I've partnered --
Let's not forget I've partnered
with the largest vending company
in the country,
and we've partnered
with the nation's largest
chocolate manufacturer, as well
as several other big brands.
It's very smart
to have point of purchase video
if you can have it
in something.
Exactly.
But on here,
do they have to be relative
to what's inside the machine,
or are you selling
advertising space to anything?
We're focused
on the differentiator.
The differentiator
is coupling retail,
point of purchase
with media,
extracting tons of data
about how consumers behave.
Guys, the valuation
is insane.
I'm out.
Thank you.
Uh, I don't like it.
What I find confusing
about it
is you're in
the advertising business,
and there's a lot of competition
for point of sale advertising,
but you're also
selling product,
but you're only selling products
that are in the machine,
and one day, maybe,
if you get big,
you'll do advertising
for other things, too.
So, is it
a display-advertising company,
or is it a pseudo vending?
This business model is
just too complicated
and unfocused for me.
I'm out.
Guys, can I ask if your balance
sheet has any debt on it?
We have
absolutely no debt.
How would you like some?
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out,
but Kevin may be interested
in Brian and Steven's
high-tech vending machine,
Vengo.
Guys, can I ask if your balance
sheet has any debt on it?
We have
absolutely no debt.
How would you like some?
I'm open to it. I'm open
to hearing what you got.
What about I lend you --
This goes into
my venture debt fund --
I give you $2 million,
and I'll take 6%
of the company in equity,
which is half of you asked.
So, $2 million in debt.
Yeah.
And...
I'll loan the company
a 36-month loan -- 3 years.
Okay.
That's enough
for proof of concept here.
$2 million,
and I want 6% of the equity
for providing
the facility.
Okay.
That's why they call me
Mr. Wonderful.
And there's no interest payments
on the debt
and there's
no strings attached?
Oh, you got to pay interest.
Are you kidding? It's a fund.
It has to make at least 7%
is my lowest rate.
Horrible!
Here is
"Mr. Advice With No Checkbook."
Isn't that wonderful?
I'm the only Shark up here --
No one's written
more checks
or bigger checks
on this show than I have,
and I'm telling you
what you already know.
It's horrible.
I have a venture debt fund.
This is what I do all day long
with tech companies.
So, Mr. Wonderful...
Yes.
...how did you calculate 6%
on the equity side?
I just asked for it.
[ Laughter ]
It's just what he wants.
It's that easy.
I just want to wet my beak
in the equity, and I deserve to.
That's a big, old beak.
I love my beak.
I look at this, and it's
a little confusing for me.
If you're going up
on a wall, right,
you're taking up that space,
so the space below it
now is empty.
I don't see why
you wouldn't lengthen that.
It's a little odd to me
at the moment.
Like, I-I personally feel
it needs some work.
Lori, is it possible,
given our asking for a
significant amount of money...
You are.
...is it possible
that you guys would consider
coming in together?
Have you guys
ever partnered up before?
O'Leary:
I think -- I think I'll bring
you in on that deal, Lori.
I mean, you've raised
a lot of money.
You're asking
for a lot of money.
With $3.4 million,
we've built a network
of 150 machines,
soon to go to 250,
we've partnered with
the largest vending company
in the country.
The vending market is a large,
slow-moving industry.
It's $7 billion.
So, there's a lot of opportunity
here to create retail.
So, if I go in with Kevin at
the deal that he offered you...
And I'd be happy to do
a debt deal with you,
but the --
the 6% is -- is --
Well, what's your counter?
My counteroffer would be
$2 million at a 7% interest rate
for 1% equity.
Oh, that's not enough.
1%?
I don't get out of bed
for that.
But also, too, we work
really hard for our money.
It's huge
to get two Sharks.
But we work hard
for our money, too.
It's huge
to get two Sharks.
You're asking for
a lot of money, though, guys.
1% is a no.
That's clear.
Yeah, that --
that doesn't work.
Brian, another counter?
That's my last counter.
1% of equity? That's all
you're willing to give up?
I'd love to make a deal
with you guys,
but it's got to be
in the range of the market.
All right, hang on. He's
about to make another counter.
I'll do the deal $2 million,
7%, 36 months, 3% equity.
You got to pay something
for two Sharks.
You don't get that --
Well, Kevin, hang on.
Is Lori in on that?
4%.
For you to do it?
2% each?
4%.
Okay, here's the deal.
We'll give you the $2 million.
I've spoken to my partner, Lori.
You get two Sharks.
It's a 7% interest loan
for 3 years,
which is enough
to prove your concept,
and we want, when we close
the deal with you,
4% equity -- 2% each.
It's a done deal, my friend,
if you say yes.
[ Chuckles ]
So, we -- we know
the venture debt market,
and what's market is
a little bit higher --
Here's the difference.
Venture debt from any firm...
Yeah.
...is one thing.
Venture debt from Mr. Wonderful
and Lori, Queen of QVC...
Yeah.
...that has
huge value to you.
You become
the "it" kids.
You're
a "Shark Tank" deal.
You've got
two sophisticated investors
from "Shark Tank"
who care about you,
and you come into
the Shark Tank ecosphere.
It's a good pitch.
All of a sudden,
you're on TV every day.
You're a great salesman.
Yeah, that's a good pitch.
So, I'm gonna provide
one more counter,
and this would be
our best offer.
We can't give out
4% equity.
What's your counter,
Brian?
It would be 2.5% of the equity,
and we'll pay you back,
and we'll work
to set the terms
that you guys
are comfortable with.
3.5%.
We'll do it --
We'll do it at 3.5%.
Ooh.
3.5% is really
too much for us.
2.5% is final offer.
And we'd love to have you guys.
[ Whispering indistinctly ]
[ Cuban chuckles ]
Okay, look, last offer,
and you should take this.
You'd be foolish not to.
We'll do it for 3%.
You got a deal.
John: Ah. Wow.
[ Chuckles ]
Greiner: Wow.
I didn't think
that was gonna happen.
Thank you, guys.
Very interested.
Glad you got this.
Thank you.
No problem.
Nice project.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
We're really excited
to have two Sharks.
Kevin's gonna bring us
his financial wizardry.
Lori's got her portfolio
of products.
We've built a big business
over the last three years,
but we're really
just scratching the surface
of what
we want to achieve,
and so we're ready
to go to the next level.
Narrator: Earlier this season,
Wombi Rose and John Wise
made a deal
with Kevin O'Leary
for their pop-up greeting-card
company Lovepop.
I have a lot of businesses
that are involved
around marriage and engagement,
and I have so many customers
that would buy this.
Narrator: Let's see
what they're up to now.
Rose:
When we pitched on "Shark Tank,"
we had $300,000 in sales
after a year and a half
in business.
In the last two months,
we've done $1 million in sales.
There are a lot of directions
we can go with Lovepop,
and we really look to Kevin
to help us pick where
we should focus our energy.
-Gentlemen.
-Hey, Kevin.
-Hey.
O'Leary:
From the moment I saw them,
I knew Lovepop would be a
success, and I was right.
These guys are killing it.
We've hit a million bucks
right out of the gate.
The plan is to hit $5 million
to $8 million this year.
In order for that to happen,
number one,
selling online direct
to our customers.
Number two,
selling big-box retailers.
And now being part of the
Something Wonderful platform,
getting into
the wedding business.
I invested in Lovepop
because they fit
on my Something Wonderful
platform,
the platform that supports
the wedding industry
and all the special moments
in people's lives.
These Lovepop cards
are perfect for that.
So, Kevin, this is
how we used your investment.
Now, that is really cool.
"Shark Tank" put us
on a national stage,
and now it's up to us
to do something
really special with it.
I love it when money just grows
on trees. That's fantastic.
Rose:
Our mission has always been
to encourage people
to tell their loved ones
that they really do care.
Thanks to the millions
of "Shark Tank" viewers
and Kevin's strategic advice,
we're able to spread
that message to everyone.
Lovepop, baby!
Oh, yeah!
[ All cheering ]
Narrator: Next into the Tank is
a convenient way to eat healthy.
Hi. I'm Karen Posada
from Austin, Texas.
My company, The Good Promise, is
seeking $100,000 for 20% equity.
Now, I'm gonna do things
a little differently.
Think of it as a wine tasting,
but without the hangover.
First, I'm gonna
pass out samples
of my delicious
vegetable smoothie blends,
and I want you
to please taste them
like you would
a full-bodied glass of red wine.
[ Chuckles ]
Well, we've come
to the right place.
[ Posada laughs ]
So, you can each grab one.
The entire tray?
Yes.
Let me give Lori hers.
She has a hard time.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you, Karen.
Hold out your pinky.
Any order you'd like us
to try these in?
No. They're all delicious.
Just go ahead and try them.
Okay. Lori, you --
you want to hold it
so you don't heat
the liquid.
[ Cuban chuckles ]
[ Laughs ]
Put the finger out.
That's it.
Okay.
Roll the blends
on the tongue,
and please tell me what flavors
you're able to identify.
Oh! This one's
really good.
That's a little ginger
in that.
Ohh!
Cuban:
Yeah, that's ginger.
What's this one?
Posada:
That is our Veggie Burst.
Each one
of our smoothie squeezes
has two servings
of veggies.
We added some zucchini,
celery, spinach.
I like this.
That one is
our Green Bloody Mary.
Can't get the kids
to eat any greens?
Have them try one of
our hidden veggie pasta sauces,
where you can sneak in
some extra goodness
without compromising
the taste.
So, which one of you is ready
to join me in my crusade
as we positively
encourage Americans
to eat more veggies
on the go?
Karen, do I buy it like that
in the plastic?
Yes, you buy it
like that.
Can I see
one of those?
Of course.
So, I buy it like this,
and I just drink it.
Mm-hmm. Yeah.
It's not a sauce.
Nope.
Karen, you know,
I have a very advanced palate.
Yes.
People know me
as a wine lover.
I've tried all of them,
as you suggested.
Ohh, my God.
Three out of four
taste like industrial waste.
Oh, come on.
This tastes like soap.
[ Coughs ]
I mean, is there
a lot of vegetables?
This one is so strong.
It's almost hard to drink.
I figured these were meant
to be mixed with something.
Yeah.
Well, I gave you two of them
that are meant to be mixed.
I gave you the Tomatillo,
the Green Bloody Mary.
John:
I have acid reflux.
Okay.
I'm -- I'm over here
burping like a choo-choo train
right now.
Is it --
Is this for a cleanse?
Because I'm hoping
that my burping
doesn't move down south,
and I have to cut this --
No, it is not
for a cleanse.
[ Laughs ]
That is way too much
information.
Well, we're about
to cut this pitch short
in a minute.
Hold on.
[ Laughter ]
No, it is not supposed to
be a cleanse.
Way too much.
[ Speaks indistinctly ]
Well, it's cleansing
right now.
O'Leary: Cleanse or no cleanse,
when do we know --
It's cleans-- It's in the middle
of cleansing right now.
So, how many have you sold?
Maybe we're wrong.
Okay, so, let me go back.
So, our first product to market
was our line of pasta sauces,
and we've sold $260,000
in 18 months.
On pasta sauces?
Not these?
Yeah.
How much of these
have you sold?
We just launched those,
so our first --
our biggest customer
is Walmart Supercenters.
But you're doing
a great job,
so why move from pasta sauces to these?
Good for you. That's good.
Well, we've had
several challenges
with our pasta sauces.
First, the retail price
is $4.99,
which proved to be
really expensive.
I'm not making enough money
with the pasta sauces.
Our markup was 23%.
Oh.
And we're not turning them
fast enough to see any capital.
So, you're selling,
but you're not making money.
Exactly.
I'm just interested --
When will these get on the shelf
so that someone can buy it,
try it,
come back,
and buy it again?
October.
These will sell for $1.99,
so we're gonna be cheaper
than the competition.
And how much is your margin
gonna be on these?
40%.
I have to be honest here.
I did not love them.
I found them a little hard
to drink.
And I think
maybe it'd be a good idea
to keep formulating
a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
Lori, but no, and I understand
where you're coming from,
but we've done -- I mean,
we tasted it with 2,000 people,
and the Veggie Burst was
one of the favorites.
Really?
Listen, you know what?
Everybody's palates
are different.
Yeah, and I --
And I truly am not trying
to put this down.
No, and that's okay.
But I definitely need
to be out on this deal.
Okay, I understand.
Herjavec:
I'll give you this credit.
We see a lot of people
on the show,
and they talk about trying
to get distribution,
and you've gotten distribution
in Walmart.
Yeah.
Cuban: Have you
raised money to do this?
I have raised money.
Um, my mom has invested
$100,000.
Ouch.
And I've raised $75,000
from angel investors.
Wow.
So, this product,
we're selling it at a price
that is so competitive.
But you're not selling it.
You haven't sold it yet.
Well, but -- Well, the price
will be at $1.99,
and there is a need
for vegetable-based products
that are convenient, that are
portable, that are affordable.
I'm just worried if somebody
actually drank the whole thing,
they'd have the dance
of the flaming sphincter.
[ Laughs ]
This thing is brutal.
Karen, I can't do it.
I just tasted it again.
I'm sorry.
I got to be out.
That's okay.
I'm out.
I don't think that --
that having a bad taste...
Mm-hmm.
...is bad.
This is good for you,
so maybe that's --
that's a marketing angle.
But the challenge with this is,
in the cold-pressed market,
people choose
very particular products.
People that generally like
this area,
which I'm one of them...
Mm-hmm.
...they like to choose
their blends.
Right.
Um, I just don't think that this
one is for me, so I'm out.
Okay. I respect that,
and so thank you so much
for saying that.
Karen, let -- let me take a stab
at this, okay?
I want to tell you a story
that's very important.
Oh, gosh. Yes.
You can't take a snail
and just eat it.
You have to purge the toxins
from its intestinal tract.
I know that when I cook it,
it won't poison me.
It has no toxins left in it.
[ Chuckles ]
This stuff tastes like a snail
that hasn't been purged.
So, make your offer,
then, Kevin.
There is no offer.
I'm out.
Yeah. Okay.
I understand that.
Thank you so much.
So, Mark, going back to where
my focus is at.
So, we're coming out with
our pre-workout, post-workout,
um, blends, as well,
and we're gonna --
we're gonna have
our veggie shots.
Okay, I'm gonna stop you
right there, right?
Yeah.
You are taking on
a lot of battles.
You have to pick --
Well, it's just flavors,
right, Mark?
But it's not
just flavors...
Different product.
...because it's how
you position yourself,
it's how you market it,
it's how people define
your brand.
When people are going to
buy this product,
they're gonna make
an instantaneous decision...
Yeah.
It's gonna be a bad one.
...against all
the other brands.
Yes.
If your message
is not crystal clear,
they're not gonna
choose you.
But, Mark,
I mean, it's, like,
you're getting two servings
of veggies per pouch, right?
Someone who's looking
for something healthier,
so I don't understand --
There's a thousand of those
out there.
We're trying to get
other business.
It's not just retail,
and I wanted you to taste --
You're taking on the world
before you've
even started selling.
That's a problem.
I'm out.
Okay.
So, you're all out. Okay.
Well, thank you.
-Thank you.
-Good luck.
It looks like the Sharks
are veggie haters,
but I'm not gonna
let that discourage me.
I wish the Sharks would have
seen past their own palate
and seen the value
of the company.
I have had
so many more challenges
that we've been able to --
to pivot and make
something great out of them,
so this will just be one more
of those experiences.
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a safer alternative
to chemical bug repellent.
Hi. My name is Stephanie Boone,
and this is Mercy.
I'm Laura Alter,
and we're from Austin, Texas.
Our company is Wondercide,
and we're seeking $500,000 in
exchange for 5% of our company.
Oh.
Wondercide solves a problem
that affects everyone.
Together: Bugs!
Ew!
Have you
ever thought about
what's actually
in the products
you use to protect your family
and pets from bugs?
These products are actually
toxic pesticides.
That's right.
We're putting them directly
on our pets, on our children.
We're spraying them
in our kitchens,
and we're sprinkling them
all over our lawns,
all because of bugs.
Wondercide is
a truly effective,
natural,
and organic product line
that kills bugs
without toxic chemicals.
Wondercide is lab-tested,
mom approved...
[ Chuckles ]
...and made in the USA.
There are really
only three things that matter
when it comes to products
that kill bugs.
First, it has to work.
Check!
[ Chuckles ]
Second,
it has to be safe.
Check!
Third, you have to be able
to get it fast.
That's why we need
your check.
[ Laughter ]
Checks.
With your help, we can replace
America's pesticides with...
Together: Wondercide!
We'll now pass out samples,
and we're happy to answer
your questions.
Thank you.
John: Thank you.
Is this for pets only?
Yes, sir, the same formulation
is effective
as an insect repellent
for people
of flea-and-tick control
for pets
and hundreds of pests
ranging from ants and mosquitoes
to even bedbugs.
And so you'd also use it to
spray elsewhere around the house
to stop mosquitoes?
In your kitchen,
carpeting, furniture.
Non-staining
and dries clear.
What separates you
from everybody else?
What makes you unique?
There's natural products for
pets today, Stephanie. I mean --
Most of the products,
both chemical and natural,
are using 95% water
and then a small amount
of active ingredient.
Our product has
no water in it.
Wondercide has the power
of a pesticide
and the safety
of food-grade ingredients.
So, I'm just trying
to understand the core market,
because you're
kind of presenting
a little bit of everything.
If we had to pick one,
our current traction
is in the pet market.
Do you have sales?
We do.
We -- We have, um,
just over $4 million in sales.
Oh!
Cuban: $50 mill.
O'Leary: Where's the $4 million
coming from?
Oh! This -- This year?
This year we're tracking
for between
$3 million
and $3.5 million.
[ All speaking indistinctly ]
Pet market. Break it down.
Break it down.
What is it?
The pet market is 75%
of that $4 million.
How'd you come up
with this?
This is Luna.
She's the reason that I --
that I founded the company.
She actually had
an adverse reaction to, uh,
a vet-prescribed monthly
flea-and-tick control product,
and, uh,
she's the reason that --
that we started
the company.
Aww.
Wow. So, how were you able
to make this compound?
So --
Like, are you a chemist?
I was a real-estate
tax accountant.
I had no formal training
in chemistry or -- or business.
And so I literally --
I quit my job,
and I literally became
this mad scientist,
and I set up my garage --
On your own?
On my own.
Have you tested it for bedbugs
or for mosquito landings?
We -- We have,
and we actually have --
We have test results
we'd love to show.
We actually have some test
results that we could show.
Oh, let's see.
We have 100% mortality
in under 30 seconds for fleas.
And then within 24 hours,
we still have 100% mortality.
The product has also been tested
against ticks and bedbugs,
and within half a minute,
there's 88% mortality,
1 minute, 94%,
and within 2 minutes,
we have 100%.
I want to know where, uh,
have the sales been coming from?
80% of our sales
are online.
Good for you.
-Wow.
-80%.
45% through our website,
35% through Amazon.
What's -- What's
your margins right now?
So, our total gross margin
for the company is 70%.
70% margin? That's like
talking dirty to me.
[ Both laugh ]
So, what are you gonna do
with the funds?
The funds we're here
to raise today
are to hire
our first key sales hire.
They're gonna hunt
600 new wholesale accounts
over the next 12 months
to generate $1 million
in additional revenue.
Why spend money on schmoes going
door to door
trying to sell
to pet stores?
So, we --
Why add this additional
risk factor
where your return probably is
not gonna be as great?
And crush your margins.
We live in a-a
convenience-driven market.
You need something,
and you need it fast.
Make no mistake -- We will
continue to hyper-focus online.
We don't intend to change
our revenue mix dramatically.
But retail,
we'll proportionately grow.
Why can't you grow
three times faster
than you are now
and avoid --
Let's partner
and figure it out.
Every Shark has
the same concern.
Retail's a different business
than what you've experienced.
I can speak canine,
and Mercy's telling me,
"Don't let these women
go into retail."
[ Cuban chuckles ]
Oh, my God.
Even the dog knows.
Well, we would certainly
appreciate --
I think that we cannot change
consumer behavior.
So, here's where
I stand with it.
Friends with, uh, Jessica Alba
and, uh, Brian,
who have The Honest Company,
and they are --
We would love
to license to them.
I mean, we're --
we're absolutely willing
to do whatever is best
for the business.
Okay.
So, I like the space.
I'll give you an offer.
Sure.
Uh, $500,000 for...
15%.
We -- We wouldn't be comfortable
doing that.
Detrimental
to our investors
and our ability to raise
in the future.
This is not just money.
You said you want us to help and
actually go to work, as well.
O'Leary: Let me structure
something a different way.
I'll give you
the $500,000, okay?
Your margins are fantastic.
You can afford to pay me
6.75% royalty
until I receive $1.5 million,
[ Whistles ]
regardless of how long
that takes.
Then that goes away.
It's gone.
It's not in perpetuity.
I've got a decent return,
but that's not all.
I want 3% equity
because I'm Mr. Wonderful.
That's actually
not a bad deal.
We could go get debt
for 6%, though.
John:
But then why are you here?
But it's not
Mr. Wonderful debt.
Alter:
That's not -- Right.
You keep telling us
why you shouldn't be here.
I-I disagree,
respectfully.
Well, why are you here, then?
You can get 6%.
O'Leary: I don't have a problem
with your business.
I have a problem
with your valuation.
5% -- You know what?
Your 5%...
There's not a chance in hell.
That's -- I'm not gonna
get up in the morning for 5%.
Narrator:
All Sharks are still in,
and Stephanie and Laura have
two offers on the table,
but the Sharks have an issue
with the high valuation
of their natural insect-
repellent company, Wondercide.
I'm not gonna
get up in the morning for 5%.
So, guys, you've done
a great job.
But there's just
a lot of confusion to me.
You say, "Okay,
we need brick and mortar
because people don't want
three-day delivery."
I don't want
to get mixed in that.
I'm out.
I believe
that the best deals are done
when both parties are
a little uncomfortable.
I have an offer standing
for $500,000 for 15%.
So, you just have to say
yes or no.
Come into my office here.
I --
Well, I --
Let's come
into Lori's office.
Greiner:
We are in Lori's office now.
Wait, wait, I --
No, I gave you an offer first.
Let's go to Lori's office.
[ All speaking indistinctly ]
Soundproof walls.
That's the ultimate counter.
[ Laughs ]
John:
Can I get an answer?
So, 5% doesn't excite me.
Okay, we could
go higher on equity
if we went higher
on cash,
higher
on the investment.
O'Leary:
I think everybody's choking
on the $10 million value,
I got to be honest
with you.
Look, Stephanie, Laura,
I-I-I can't get excited,
like Lori said, for that amount,
and I don't want to put up
more money for this.
Um, I just don't know the scope
of the market at this point.
Great job, though.
Thank you.
I'm out.
Let me make a suggestion
that may help here, okay?
Lori, you don't like the 5%.
Let me suggest something.
Come into my offer,
because you're gonna get
your money back times two.
Three times.
Yes.
You're gonna
get your cash back.
Greiner:
I have an offer for you.
$500,000, 50 cents
every unit sold, whatever sold,
until I get my money back,
then 3% equity in the company.
Wow.
It's a good deal.
[ Whispers indistinctly ]
Daymond, would you be --
Would you guys
be interested in --
in doing a deal
like that together?
So, you're gonna give him
50 cents, too?
They'd have to sell
a million units
before you get
your capital back.
I'm not --
I'm not interested in that deal.
You know how far
and fast this can go?
I mean...
That's a crazy offer.
[ Chuckles ] It's a really good
offer. What's your decision?
[ Both speaking indistinctly ]
'Cause things can happen.
Things can change here
quickly.
Yeah.
Okay, Lori,
we'd love to do that deal.
Yay! Whoo!
Whoo!
'Cause they were talking.
Something
was gonna happen.
Yay, girls.
Mercy,
we're gonna do a deal!
I like it.
Yay.
I have been wanting to do
something like this a long time.
Thank you.
We're so excited.
Thank you, everyone.
We appreciate.
We appreciate your time.
You did a great job, guys.
Thank you.
It was clear
that Lori wanted to make a deal.
She wanted a little something
more than just the equity,
so by lowering her equity
and giving her a royalty
on every product sold,
we are perfectly aligned with
Lori's interest and to ours,
and we know
we're gonna change the world.